things aren't coming as easy for you
this year
is that a safe way to look at it that
thing i feel
um you know it's a lot of it's a lot of
schemes you know we're going to get
defenses
um they calling out our police stuff
like that like they know what we're
doing so
a lot of that you know sometimes you
know stuff won't go our way
if they beat us to the punch so you're
you're hearing on the other side of the
line of scrimmage the defense calling
out your place
yeah they definitely do like run stuff
like that watch out for this watch out
for that sometimes that's what's going
on
so how do you how do you combine that
lamar so
we i guess we're going to have time and
let coach you know
let us know what he sees upstairs and we
just go from there
and after that exchange between our next
guest rich eisen and lamar jackson the
ravens decided never to let lamar
jackson be interviewed by anyone ever
again see what you did oh
gosh
you know what mike it's it was a it was
a an open-ended
sort of question that um i think
everyone wants to know is
why why are things looking so much more
um difficult and that was the answer he
gave
which was honest and and i i love the
kid the kid's
awesome and uh i do hope to have him
back on the rich eisen show
another well offensive coordinator greg
roman downplayed it yesterday
as a coach would be likely to do
he's not going to say oh crap lamarr why
did you do this
but there is something to that now some
teams are so good it doesn't matter you
can call out hey here's what we're doing
good luck stopping it but
that's just one of those little things
that gives a defense an edge if they can
pick up
through film study what's coming if they
know what's coming
and they're yelling it out and they're
freaking out the offense that gives the
defense a little bit of a benefit when
it comes to stopping what the offense
wants to do
no doubt about it mike and you know i
had greg cosell
on on on my show yesterday
um and asked him um from his all 22
maven perspective does he see anything
on film that could
pick that up that he's been able to sit
there and go well the defense certainly
blew off the ball
on that one and looked like they might
have known what was coming and his
answers
was no that he hasn't seen that on film
but what he does see on film is an
offense that he called remedial
now that's the issue here you know um
i honestly do not think i've i've been
around lamar jackson
um um out you know away from the
football field i've been with him
um you know at corporate events that
i've hosted i've seen him around people
i've seen him
by himself you know in a room where he's
not you know on
and i don't think this is a guy who's
got an agenda at all
like you know what he's chafing that the
plays are being called in a certain way
that
that the defenses are on to it so let
him
you know you know go on a national show
and throw his coaches under the bus i
legitimately think he was just
innocently just telling the truth and
uh so i don't see that this is an issue
between quarterback
and coaching staff and i i do see it as
they have a personnel issue potentially
uh
in terms of who who are defensive
coordinators circling
uh that they're con that they're afraid
of other than
lamar maybe it's mark andrews and then
the scheme
from everybody that i've been talking to
who's expert at this
is is lacking um and maybe this is a
tendency breaker that can start with
the information that lamar threw out on
my show
and i agree with you i don't think it
was in any way
malicious i don't think it was
calculated it was just
sometimes a guy opens his mouth
and the truth comes out and we're used
to a sport where
there's always that obfuscation there's
always that
that lie because lying is part of the
strategy you don't come out and
and just lay it all out what you're
planning to do on anything football
related that's what made it so stunning
to me
yeah you know look uh like i said um
he's taken on new england
um new england um got a major handful of
him
and mark ingram who hasn't looked the
same this year
and um that was last year um and that
was
essentially the high water mark or the
beginning of the end of
of new england's 2019 season if you
think about it
you know miami had a better record after
uh halloween than new england did
uh new england went into that game
undefeated so clearly they they
know what's coming at them um and
this would be the worst possible team
one would think to face
uh if the defense is aware of what's
coming at them
so that's kind of a backdrop to this
thing no question about it but i i do
expect the ravens to win this game
and then you know they've got a tough
game against i believe it's tennessee
before taking on pittsburgh
on thanksgiving night on nbc is the back
end of that triple header which is going
to be amazing
so there's the the division is not lost
um lamar is still supremely talented the
question is is what can they do
to switch things up in a way or be more
efficient on that side of the ball that
they've definitely had problems doing so
far
here's the real question when sunday
comes around rich after you and your
colleagues on nfl
game day morning on nfl network all
select
the ravens to win and after all of us on
football night in america
select the ravens to win how long will
it take the patriots to troll
everyone if the patriots win the game
well i don't whichever millennium
millennial that's running their account
um i i imagine um you know or
whoever runs that account and maybe uh
feeds
belichick's nike the dog or whoever has
that role
uh in new england because that's the way
it goes you know we all were in that
same boat
um last sunday night where we all took
the bucks and the saints
um had their fun same thing with the
bill social media account where everyone
essentially
industry-wide chose seattle look i mean
that is the nature of what we do for a
living um
where we opinionate and you know not all
of it
works out and i i fully admit that i
don't know everything
but that said i think this past sunday
was the was the
quintessential given sunday right um
where anything happens and that you
don't expect anything to happen so
that's my kids and my dogs in the
other room um so this is one of those
crazy seasons where you really can't
figure anything out
with any sense of normalcy um from
anything
uh whether it's obviously the way that
the patriots and the chiefs played a
game earlier this year then the titans
and the
and the bills played a game this year
and the titans and the steelers played a
game this year
everything's thrown out the window in
that regard and then
honestly i don't think you can with any
certainty other than
kansas city say that the given sunday is
mostly going to be theirs
even though they did suffer one of those
against the raiders
a prominent player encroached on our
opinionation
turf earlier today deandre hopkins
suggesting
that all defensive pass interference
yards should
count toward the receiver's stats
i like it and i may have like pondered
that from time to time i never really
articulated it never really made the
argument before but but i can get behind
this one i like the idea
of is the spot foul give the guy the
yards if he presumably would have caught
the pass
go ahead and give him the yards for the
defensive pass interference
amen uh as somebody who has both kyler
murray and deandre hopkins in two
fantasylands
uh last week when i was noticing when i
was noticing that xavier howard's
um strategy was to literally foul
deandre hopkins on every play
um and that was their strategy like
truly
they you know i know that he had what a
season low
three catches or three targets or
whatever the hell it is
um his catch radius is like 90 feet wide
he can get open
however he wants um so it i understand
that his point is like look you know i'm
not getting the stats because i'm being
fouled every play it's sort of like
pack a deandre you know um and that
might be a way to work it
but that's another thing that i was
pointing out on my show as well
is the other day is anytime i see
hopkins just
snatch the ball out of the air or get
open
at will literally at will and there's
not many receivers who can do that
obviously somebody like julio jones
leaps to mind in that
in that regard how in the hell
did the texans not get a one back for
the upgrade
honestly like how did that happen mike
how seriously yeah and and they took a
gu they took a guy that the cardinals
could not wait to get rid of in david
johnson they wanted to unload that 10
million
guaranteed salary if anything it should
have been a one plus to take david
johnson and get de'andre hopkins back i
i agree with you completely
hey it's now friday your jets played
monday night
adam gase has not been fired yet it
looks like he's the guy
for the duration of the season how
surprised are you that he's still on the
job
well not at all to be honest with you um
it's not like that there are fans in the
stands booing their heads off
um making it more and more difficult
that you have to
um you have to satisfy you know to make
sure that the fans still come to the
game there's no fans in the stands
i'm serious i think that has to play a
role in it the fact that the johnson
family since they've owned it have never
fired a coach in the middle of the
season either
um so this is kind of par for the course
as we know
uh the owner of the jets is currently um
serving um the uh current administration
as the ambassador to the uk so
um i'm imagining that this is going to
be something that
everybody knows is going to be addressed
at the end of the season
you know what also what are you going to
do you're going to
stick greg williams in front of the new
york media as the de facto coach for the
next seven weeks
i mean uh it makes it makes total sense
to just
keep this as is the only issue that that
it
it does appear to um uh keep
alive is the non-stop drum beat from
members of the media steve young being
the latest on monday night football to
say trevor lawrence
should consider not entering the draft
this year you and i have talked about it
when you appeared on my show a couple
weeks ago
because the jets are so clueless as if
the jets
won't fire adam gase the first second
it is expedient for them to do it and
that this is with trevor lawrence
being out there the only chance the jets
have to get a top-notch coaching
candidate you could pretty much
like throw it out there and say who
wants to coach trevor lawrence and be
attached to
trevor lawrence's hip in the new york
media market to start your career as
well as a coach or
somebody who i adore and i i don't know
if he'd be interested but
i i would write a blank check and tell
david shaw we want you to come to new
york and be this guy
to hook up with trevor lawrence would
that be something he'd be interested in
eric the enemy bring your playbook
from kansas city would trevor lawrence
really say no to that i
you know also knowing that his team's
got a second first round draft choice
that belongs to seattle's
um on top of all of it it makes no sense
that he would turn down being broadway
trevor
because of the fact that the jets have
been so dysfunctional the past few
months and years
uh that's the only thing about firing
gates that keeps that
narrative going but i hope lawrence
ignores it
i see two wild cards in all of this you
mentioned woody johnson one thing we
know
is he will be back we don't know when
but he will be back and secondly
secondly
peyton manning is a name that i keep an
eye on here
because is there a way maybe just maybe
that peyton manning could get to trevor
lawrence and
tell him you'll be fine with gase
because i was fine with gase
and look at what i did with gase i don't
know that there's anything peyton
manning can say
do you think there's a way that peyton
manning could convince trevor lawrence
to work with gays uh i i think it's a
moot point man
adam gets over man it's over
it's over and anybody that you know
again i i don't proclaim to be
um an all 22 expert i am not
okay i am not but everybody i talk to
says part of the reason why gays
and and sam darnold is not a good mix is
that gays does bring the peyton manning
system or
sensibility with him uh peyton doesn't
like
pre-snap motions he didn't like that he
he could walk to a line of scrimmage and
know what the defense is thinking before
you know it
the fact that the jets don't run very
much motion does not help a quarterback
that's still learning how to
operate in the nfl it's insane nothing
that the jets do
appears to be appropriate or working at
all
and that's unfortunate for adam gase but
there is no
way i would even if peyton manning even
if archie himself
says look we did this with eli this is
not
the way you should handle this here
either uh it's it's a moot point there
is no way
especially since the general manager
didn't hire this coach
he didn't hire this coach he also didn't
acquire le'veon bell
he was left with a whole big stinking
pile
that i imagine he will take the ability
to get his own coach
i don't know who that is but again if it
is trevor lawrence coming for the jets
um it's on but if it's not trevor
lawrence it could be justin fields it's
possible
that that might attract the right coach
they had one in matt rule and said he
was too green
his staff was too green so instead they
let him go
and they let robbie anderson go to him
and now we're seeing what matt rule and
robbie anderson would have looked like
together it's
bat guano insane it is terrible so i
understand why people are saying
that trevor lawrence should avoid this
fire that's a dumpster
but i i still believe again that joe
douglas
uh from from anybody who knows him says
that he does know what he is doing that
he is
worthy of this opportunity they do have
a lot of draft choices they do have some
people that have
that have flashed but they just get
trevor lawrence
with all due respect to sam darnold let
him go somewhere else let him find
his next spot that he deserves to find
another spot
uh and i think another team would
definitely take him and you've mentioned
the teams too
uh pittsburgh being one that might uh
want to go grab him if the jets want to
send him elsewhere
potentially san francisco might be
interested in him other teams are going
to be
definitely looking for quarterbacks the
bears i imagine will be in the market
for a quarterback too
uh very soon so um
i think that's the future i just don't
imagine peyton manning or any manning
arch
archie cupper eli olivia name the
manning i don't think there's any
manning that's going to save adam
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports